[Musique]
et aujourd'hui c'est inviter ses vous
pierre jacquemot bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
vous avez notamment été ambassadeur de
france au kenya au ghana en rdc chef de
mission coopération burkina au cameroun
vous enseignez notamment à sciences po
vous collaborez avec l'iris ou présider
le groupe initiative qui oeuvre au
développement c'est l'une de vos tâches
importantes depuis de nombreuses années
le développement en afrique et à travers
le monde vous êtes l'auteur de plusieurs
essais dont celui ci c'est le dernier
afrique la démocratie à l'épreuve vos
aux éditions jean jaurès il a fait suite
à un essai qui était déjà sur la
démocratie et sur le vote en afrique il
y a deux ans à peu près c'est un
complément avec notamment les récents
coups d'état en afrique de l'ouest au
sahel le passage du coc vide est
également
vous intéresser en gros fragilité de la
démocratie sur le continent africain
lors nuance aussi selon le pays selon le
contexte
d'abord on va faire basique qu'est ce
que c'est qu'une démocratie et est ce
que ce mot a une définition différente
ou une perception différente selon le
lieu où on se trouve
démocratie et d'avoir des philippaerts
sont les modalités de sa mise en place
les préalables qu'il suppose c'est à
dire l'élection
de ces de ses gouvernants
élections selon différentes modalités on
a veillé à kankan somalie des élections
c'est un suffrage indirect ou bien un
suffrage direct et puis plus
fondamentalement la démocratie c'est un
art de vivre ensemble dans le respect de
des principales libertés
liberté de vie liberté d'expression
liberté de de circulation et un ensemble
d'institutions qui doivent garantir sa
liberté
des institutions de type cour
constitutionnelle
l'indépendance de la magistrature de
l'ensemble du fonctionnement du système
judiciaire donc c'est un ensemble de
deux pratiques mises en place par le
truchement d'une élection et qui ont
connu un développement en afrique depuis
une trentaine d'années
vous énumérez que le nombre d'élections
à travers le continent africain c'est
impressionnant 630 présidentielle et
législatives depuis 1990
pourquoi et est ce que pour autant il
n'y a pas de 2,2 de deux grandes
démocraties africaines et au contraire
le retour de certains coups d'état en ce
moment alors oui ça fait à peu près 2 va
peut-être d'élection par an donc il ya
matière pour le pour le chercheur a
étudié les processus
comme je l'aï dit tout à l'heure les
élections pluripartites met en oeuvre
plusieurs plusieurs un système
concurrent qui ment qui met en place
des dispositifs qui garantissent à
plusieurs parties plusieurs candidats ou
candidates de se présenter concurremment
l'ail et des résultats très très
variable peut-être on peut on peut
commencer par les les systèmes qui ont
les pays qui ont plutôt réussi dans ce
cheminement démocratique tel que nous
européens on l'entend la démocratie
libérale reprennent en novembre par les
aventures des garanties bon il ya des
des exemples vertueux consiste
fréquemment le il ya un trio de tête qui
sort le plus souvent c'est maurice à
l'autre extrême c'est le calvaire très
souvent c'est le botswana un petit peu
moins souvent mais ils appartiennent
quand même cette catégorie le ghana ou
le où le sénégal qui garantissent une
certaine alternance qui ont connu de
l'alternance au pouvoir l'alternance est
un critère de bonne qualité d'une
démocratie représentative
justement dans votre livre vous vous
détailler un peu les les différents
critères internationaux et de certains
de certains instituts pour classer les
démocraties observer leur leur évolution
si on l'a juste en seul critère de
l'élection la démocratie elle est
partout tout le temps mais c'est pas il
simple le vote il est apparu d'abord
vous l'expliquer un tout petit peu avant
les indépendances pour des élections
locales ensuite il n'ya donc les années
60 les indépendances des élections qui
vont généraliser qui seront pas
complètement démocratique des régimes à
parti unique des démocratures c'est
vraiment dans les années 90 que les
choses vont vont fondamentalement changé
en quoi exactement est l'élément
déclencheur c'est le bénin alors on
associe souvent et à mon avis à tort
l'élément déclencheur un célèbre
discours de françois mitterrand à la
baule mais avant ce discours le bénin a
mis en place ce qu'on a ce qu'on
appelait les conférences nationales et
une quinzaine de pays ont connu à ce
moment là une conférence nationale c'est
à dire une revendication populaire
incarnée par les différentes forces
vives pour participer à l'élection
dans la pluralité de lors de leurs
aspirations et leurs tendances alors
qu'autrefois ce qui dominait c'était le
parti unique il y avait des élections
mais c'était le parti unique on venait
entériné occupé sorte une situation de
fait ou ce qu'ils dominaient c'était le
coup d'état les pratiques du coup d'état
ont été très importantes après les
indépendances donc là il ya eu un
changement assez assez générales et
aujourd'hui on n'est pas par des cas
tout à fait aberrant le seul pays où le
vote pas en afrique les l'erythrée ça
n'étonnera personne d'état régime
complètement autocratique est
complètement fermée mais pour le reste
partout on est devant une pluralité de
choix savais pas du tout cela fonctionne
pour autant mais il ya au moins cette
garantie justement dents cassées années
90 avec une véritable ouverture et puis
il ailleurs les dirigeants dans les
années 90 2000 qui vont modifier la
constitution pour pouvoir se maintenir
au pouvoir viendront aussi les
différents printemps les révolutions qui
vont faire tomber ben ali moubarak
kadhafi à béchir ali abdallah saleh est
ce qu'on est en train de vivre en ce
moment une nouvelle période charnière
pour la démocratie en afrique alors
l'afrique connaît un dérèglement
climatique et j'ajoute que l'afrique
connaît un dérèglement démocratique un
gars qui se traduit par ce que vous
dites à savoir des entorses au code de
la route qui est la constitution
la l'élection c'est un permis de
gouverner
mais encore faut-il pouvoir connaître et
respecter le code de la route et on
s'aperçoit qu'ils étendent entorses au
code de la route vous l'avez cité de
l'est troisième mandat et il ya au moins
une dizaine de chefs d'état qui sont
maintenues au-delà des règles
constitutionnelles le sava de ouattara
alpha condé et pour ceux qui consomment
alpha condé ça c'est ça s'est mal
terminée donc il ya un certain nombre
d'entorses ensuite ya une certaine
fatigue du vote on s'aperçoit que les
jeunes votent peu voire pas des femmes
votent peu ou pas vous allez me dire
c'est pas un phénomène typiquement
africain ca phénomène universel pour
voter dans notre en france par exemple
autre chose c'est très peu d'alternance
l'alternance le principe de l'alternance
est un principe démocratique fondamental
la possibilité de changer de tête
or il ya énormément de facteurs de
blocage qui empêche cette alternance et
on se retrouve avec des régimes ou
mussolini
en ouganda
sassou n'guesso congo paul biya au
cameroun sont là depuis depuis deux pays
depuis très longtemps on voir même on
voit même des transferts dynastique
c'est le cas c'est le chaos qu au gabon
c'est le cas au togo c'est le cas à
djibouti où j'étais là on aime les
choses changent alors il ya des
situations les les choses changent mais
lorsque ça change ça vient plutôt de la
rue et la société civile le facteur
novateur enfin l'élément porteur de deux
changements durables démocratique au
sens la démocratie substantielle les
libertés fondamentales ne ne passe plus
par les urnes mais passe or les urnes
par des mouvements citoyens qui
revendique cette liberté fondamentale
pour eux et pour leur entourage agissent
pour renforcer cette liberté demande des
comptes demande des comptes aux
politiciens voir les sanctionne voilà
donc c'est plutôt à l'intérieur de ceux
de ce monde foisonnant de la société
civile que les changements
importance advienne il ya les pays où il
ya une déliquescence de l'état et des
militaires en profite c'est le cas de la
guinée ou encore du mali c'est ça qui
explique vraiment cessé coup de force
militaire qu'on voit encore aujourd'hui
alors qu'on pensait être relégués aux
années 70 chaque situation est
spécifique on est devant 54 et aillent
très difficile de faire des généralités
mais ce qu'on peut constater par exemple
dans le cas du dans le cas de la guinée
c'est qu'elle faconde et avait forcé les
urnes en décrochant un troisième mandat
et ça s'est mal terminée dans le cas du
mali est également du burkina faso qui
sont deux pays qui ont connu récemment
coup d'état on est dans une situation où
le système démocratique tel qu'il était
en place incarné par un chef d'état a
été
incapable d'assurer une forme sont
fondamentales pour la population qui la
sécurité de sécurité des personnes et
des biens est donc devant ce constat
d'incapacité l'armée sait s'y substituer
aux institutions démocratiques et on
peut voir que ces putschs revoir aux
calendes sérère aux calendes malienne
aux calendes wolof le le le l'élection
et on voit d'ailleurs la difficulté avec
la cedeao que l'organisation régionale
incarné par les chefs d'état qui sont
asti sont des institutions démocratiques
la difficulté d'un de relation puisque
les putschs réclame trois ans qu'à 35
ans avant de passer à l'élection
justement malgré les modes de
communication et d'échangés entre les
populations aujourd'hui parce que les
vrais contestation via les réseaux
sociaux pour communiquer les groupes
whatsapp en afrique ça marche beaucoup
malgré le travail des ong celui des
grandes instances comme la cedeao
pourquoi ce qu'il ya encore aujourd'hui
des démocratures en afrique il y allant
démocrature s'éteint à ceci le mot
démocratie avec dictature donc on voit
bien que ce sont bd des régimes forts
ils sont cent ils ont des idées figurent
un port pour l'afrique la figure de paul
kagamé au rwanda et
et probablement l'une d'entre elles
celle de miss wenig également une entre
elles je dois dire des rdt ce sont les
figures qui ont fasciné l'occident un
certain moment est probablement ce
disant il faut des régimes un peu dure
un peu autoritaire la démocratie c'est
pas tout à fait au sens libéral du thème
c'est pas tout à fait mûr vin n'est pas
nenê n'est peut-être c'est peut-être
trop tôt de mettre en place et il faut
donc des régimes autoritaires des
régimes forts qui assurent la sécurité
dans le pays et prennent en charge un
certain nombre de fonctions que des
régimes où dérivent des démocraties mal
comme il en existe sont incapables
d'assurer qu' donc effectivement il ya
il ya une certaine fascination pour des
régimes qui nous nous pourrions jugé
comme étant des autocraties dans selon
notre propre système de valeurs et qui
sont relativement populaire dans le
contexte africain berl et les coups
d'état dont on a parlé tout à l'heure on
parle certes pour certains d'entre eux
notamment du mali de coup d'état
populaire mais qui est une assise
populaire alors que ça peut choquer des
démocrates pur et dur
un régime militaire ne peut pas
évidemment représenter l'idéal l'idéal
politique pour ces populations et on
salue d'ailleurs ceux qui nous regardent
au mali via internet via les réseaux
sociaux c'est qu'on y est on est
interdit de diffusion avec nos confrères
de rfi au home alliés et certains
maliens tente toujours de rester
informés grâce à à france 24 et un débat
passionnant pierre jacquemot je reviens
voulu qu'on ait encore quelques minutes
supplémentaires pour parler ensemble de
ce livre s'appelle la démocratie à
l'épreuve tôt aux éditions de la
fondation jean jaurès ça vient de sortir
tout récemment merci beaucoup d'avoir
été notre invité ce matin et à très
bientôt sur france 24